I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office Ladies. Good morning, lady.
Oh, we have a really amazing guest on Office Ladies today. We sure do. All of you that listened to Workbus last week know that today in the studio, we have Brian Cranston. We cannot wait for you guys to hear this interview because, look, there are certain episodes of the office that are just real big episodes and they warrant extra time. And Workbus is definitely one of those. It's definitely one of those. Yeah. And we shared all about our experience on that bus, but we really felt like you needed to hear from the director as well. So we reached out to Brian. He was so kind and gracious. He came into the studio and chatted all things workbuss with us. And more. Now, I know a lot of people know Brian Cranston from his many acting roles.
He's been in film and television and he's been on Broadway. You know, there's Malcolm in the middle and Walter White on Breaking Bad. And he even won a Tony Award for the Broadway play all the way. He's amazing. But Brian is also a very accomplished director. He directed episodes of Malcolm in the middle of Breaking Bad, Modern Family, Sneaky Pete, and his new series, Your Honor, on Showtime, and of course, this very epic famous episode of The Office. And he is just delightful.
He's so much fun to talk to. It was such a joy having him. And Jenna, you know what? I was thinking, we didn't bring this up to him, but I want him to direct our road trip movie if we ever do it. Oh, my gosh, yes. We've never even shared. Have we shared about the fact that me and you and Lee have a road trip idea? We came up with an idea for a road trip movie.
Lee wrote it. It's so funny. It's so funny. I know. Some of the hardest I have laughed in a long time was when the three of us were sitting at your dining table and we were pitching jokes. Because listen, you guys, this is a road trip movie about two gals that are like in their 50s. Yes. But anyway, I mean...
It has a mom detective's element to it, I have to say. It really does. Yeah. But would Brian Cranston ever direct anything on the road again? That's the question. I think after you listen to this interview, you might find that he would be very hesitant to do so. Well, listen, the office might have ruined him forever in directing anything in a moving vehicle again. But let's let him tell you about it.
we're going to take a break. And when we come back, our interview with Brian Cranston about work bus, which is also known as Death Bus. We'll be right back. It's such a great interview. We'll be right back. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Rackaton. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Racketon, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook,
to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love, and cashback is automatically added to your account, and you can choose to get paid via Interacte Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases. Just go to racketon.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N.
Terms and Conditions Apply. Yeah. Yeah. Well, who wrote your opening theme song? Creege Breton. Did he really? You know, I just realized who Creed was. You just did.
I just in the last few. weeks. Grassroots, all of that. Yes, the grassroots. And I'm thinking, that can't be the same. It's the same guy. Yes. Now, my question to you, my first question, thanks for coming on the show, by the way.
My first question to you would be, did the show ever do a backstage idea about what Creed's background was? Did someone ever go, that guy looks so familiar? And, you know, did you ever do anything like that? I don't remember. There were so many pictures. There were so many people who wanted to do a whole episode just on Creed and his life and wanted him to be outed as Creed Bratton, Creed Bratton, because he's the only person on the show who has his full name as his character name. Like Angela is Angela on the show, but on the show, her last name is Martin. But Creed Bratton, the character is also Creed Bratton, the man.
But I don't think it was ever revealed. I will say, though, of all the characters, we have a show Bible. Sorry. I have to, you guys, Brian, his microphones this morning, something's up with it. And there is a bar in front of his face. And so for me to talk to Brian, he has to look, lean around the bar. It's safer to have a bar in front of my face. It helps the restraining order issue that we have. That we have. But anyway, of all the characters had a, we had a show Bible of all their back history. And creeds is the craziest. It's the most. He has like, he has like a family in Canada. He lives under his desk half the time. He's, it's like all over the place. Wait a minute.
Why didn't I get a chance to read that? That would have been very- They didn't give you the show Bible? No, I didn't get it. No one said it was available. Been given that. I absolutely should have been given that. Would have changed work bus.
I'm going to quit. Retroactive. Well, we always like to ask people when they come on. First question, how did you end up working on the office? How'd you get this job directing work bus? Tracy Katsky is a friend of mine, and she was working as a consultant with David in the last year you guys were on the air. Okay. Right?
And I had just finished my season with Breaking Bad, and that was 2012. Yep. I think. It was 2012. And Tracy calls and says, we're looking for directors for this new season. would you be interested in coming on board the office? And immediately the answer was going to be, of course, no. But I love the show.
It's such a legendary show that any chance to be a part of it in some small way. And she said, I know you've been directing Breaking Bads and, you know, you're out in the desert and it's hot and it's sticky. How would you like to come to, what was it, Burbank, North Hollywood, wherever we were. And we work inside. Yeah. It's a short day. Air conditioned.
Air conditioned. Easy. Yeah. Indoor's five days. Bang, bang, bang. Boom, boom. And I said, oh, it sounds fantastic. Let's do it. And she said, well, we have such and such slot open.
And I looked at my calendar. I said, I'll take that slot. Yeah. And I don't know. You probably described it on your show before. But the way it works in television for directors is by time. You have no idea when you sign on to a show what your episode is going to be at the time it gets to your time slot. So we had no idea. And it just so happened that
work bus came onto my lap. What did you think when you read this episode? Well, the first, I was excited to read it, read it right away. And, work bus. Oh, I don't know. Oh, they, oh, they exterminate. Was it exterminating? No, we were exterminated. This is 11 years ago, I think. There was this electrical issue, magnet, electromagnetic things in the walls, and Dwight was going to have to open up all the walls and redo the electrical. So, so the basic idea is that there could not be a work stoppage for the whole team. So a work bus was found to be. the best method to continue working while this work on the actual location. The office was taking
place. So everybody had to load onto the bus. Desks were on there, as we all know, and we had to just keep traveling. We're in the San Fernando Valley in August. It's so hot in August. I went to the call sheets. It was 100 degrees this week. It was like triple digits. It was very hot. So the first thing I did was curse my friend Tracy Katzky and said, damn you as if they knew, you know. But it was a, it was a challenge. I think we shot in
on the set for a day and a half or something like that. Yeah, yeah. And then the rest of the time we were on a bus. On that bus or in the park. And then we were at a baseball field. I know we were. Yep. Right. We had that cold open. Yeah. I enjoyed
it for the most part. But there was a there were some tough moments well i have to say okay you know that our cast has renamed this episode death bus this has come to you i know and jena and i wrote a whole chapter in our book about it the office pfs we have a copy for you we signed inside it says brian we owe you our lives thanks angela and jena it is chapter 12 and um we dedicated a whole chapter to just this episode. And we have fantastic photos of you, but we realized after our book came out, you were doing press.
We felt really bad because every single producer clearly wanted you to be asked about death bus. Jenna was like, oh, no, Ange. We wrote about this, and now everyone is asking him the same question on every talk show. Why did you try to kill the cast of the office? Why did I try to kill the cast? Was it a murder for hire? No one's asked. I can't discuss all those details.
There is a current investigation going on. Ongoing, ongoing. And, you know, indictments will be handed down. I have every reason to believe you two are in the clear. I can't be positive on that, but I have a set of circumstances. It was hot and tight. You know, you talk about the set being contained. Well, we're on a bus and we didn't have a lot of room.
And if I recall, nothing was actually nailed down. Everything was kind of shifting around desks were actually shifting and moving. And I'm looking at this going, oh, my God, I think people didn't realize this bus is actually on the road on an open street and moving. Well, at first there was comedy in that, right?
Like, at first, we're traveling down the road and, like, our little coffee cup is moving across the dead. Are we papers? You're holding on to things. Yeah. We hit a pot hole. My lamp slid in my lap.
I caught it. Yay. That's funny. It's funny. But then... But then there was a part of the script where I guess Dwight swerves and we all kind of slide, and we all are like, ah.
Yeah, he's trying to get us to the pie. Yeah, get to the pie. And I guess the AD yelled to the cast. We weren't really swerving. So, lean right, and we got to, ah! And no one bought it. It didn't look good. And so then they unloaded rain.
Rain left, and a stunt driver got on the bus. Right. They removed us from the tow rig, and now we are truly just a bus traveling down the road with a stunt driver. We listed what all was in the bus. Like, we went back and screen grabbed it. It was a full, like, Arrowhead Water Jug dispenser, a microwave, a coffee pot, lamps, rolling chairs, desks, computers, a printer. Was there a little mini X-Rox machine?
I bet there was. So it was a full office. And it all, when the stunt driver swerved right, it all, it all swerved. Everything moved. And all of a sudden, that was not part of the production discussion that we had, by the way. It was like, we're doing this. Rain's going to drive and we're going to do this. And it's all contained and we'll have the cast move back and forth.
It didn't look good. Everybody was in sync. And there was something funny about things happening at the same time and once. And you can't duplicate that. You can't fake that, yeah. And so there was an idea, and I don't believe it was my idea, but I'm not saying it's not to actually heighten the movement of the thing with a professional stunt driver. Yes, it was a professional stunt driver.
It wasn't Rain Wilson. We, however, are not professional stunt people. This is true. And this is where the beginning of the indictments will start. Yes. And the reality of it in retrospect, you look back and you go, oh, my God, what were we doing? Oh, and then. Oh, wait, wait.
We don't want to get to that part yet. Wait, I have to ask, you're not on the bus with us at this point. You're in like a follow van, and you're watching this footage on a screen. What? Hang on. I was in the bus the entire time. Wait, you were in the bus? Yeah.
For that moment? I was in the very back. And the way back on the back row. I was down on. I remember that. I was on the floor with a little viewfinder and watching the thing as I'm moving back and forth to. I remember that. knew you were on the bus most of the time, but I thought there were a few shots where it was like
we had to clear everybody. We cleared boom. We had just camera. And I did not know that you still stayed on. I stayed on when it was, when there was room, when we were shooting, when I was able to hide in the back on the ground. When there was no room and shooting in one direction, I think I was off the bus. Because it was too dangerous. And I said, I shouldn't be on this. I shouldn't be here. We did skip over. So, Jen and I, we were, like, trying to remember everything about this episode and filming it. And we were like, wait, we all had to get off the bus three times. The first one was because we got so tickled in Ellie peed her pants.
Yep. Remember? And we had to change her clothes. I didn't know if you were going to actually talk about this. Oh, no, Ellie. Don't worry. It's in the book. It's in the book.
Ellie is such a good sport. She's such a good sport. And we all laughed. And it wasn't a huge pee. It was just a little. She actually did. Yeah. So then, oh, whoops.
It wasn't just a saying. Yeah. So we all pulled over. We hung out in the park. Ellie changed clothes. Then we all get back on the bus. And I remember Jenna, like us being like, this is crazy. What a crazy day thinking like, that's the craziest thing that'll happen.
Then the swerve and everything flew. I remember digging creed out of a pile of things. Do you remember that? Creed was totally covered. It was dangerous. Yeah. I look back on an hour, and it was, I would like to think that that wouldn't happen today. It would all be zip-tied or...
Yeah, something. Here's the thing. Our show did not travel well. We were very good at shooting inside of an office. But pretty much any time we left to go on the road, even just metaphorically, the wills came off the bus. Something happened. Yeah, we lost half the cast at sea.
Yeah. Oh, that episode when you're on. A booze cruise. Me, Phyllis, Brian, and Rain drifted out to see for about 20 minutes. On a dingy. It's like 4.30 in the morning. 4.30 in the morning. Yes, because we were shooting nights.
And you had the choice. You know, we were wrapped. They were doing the scene with Jim and Pam. They're like, do you want to stay on the boat until we wrap or do you want to leave? And only this small group raised their hands because we had to kind of climb down a ladder, hop on a dingy. To get back to shore. Yeah, and then the engine broke down. And then the engine broke and they lost them and we floated.
Let's take a moment and think about them for just a second. They were such great cast members. And the famous thing is that everyone was like, we lost Phyllis. And me and Brian and Rain were like, Ann, and Angela, hello. People only cared about Phyllis. I know, I know. Sweet Phyllis. Sweet Phyllis.
Well, it's true that whenever we left set, things happened. So we're sorry. It was hard. Well, okay, so there was a second thing that happened then. We unpiled ourselves. There was, then we were hot. And I remember being so excited after lunch. Didn't you guys have to turn the air off when we were filming?
Because it was loud. The AC and the bus was loud. Yes. It was loud. So there was this announcement, guys, we have a great thing. We have a portable AC unit that we're going to pull on a trailer. behind the bus, and we have a hose that is going to go up through, like, this sunroof thing in the bus, and it'll be quiet.
We can leave it on while we're filming. You guys aren't going to be hot anymore, and we couldn't believe our look. We were so excited. This is fresh, wonderful, cool air. People were getting wilty. Yeah. So we were, like, in a hot tin can. It was really tough.
And Sanfordana Valley, like you said, it was 100 degrees. Yeah. And then we made it worse by having the clothes. closed up windows and everything else to where the heat inside that bus, I would think would be 110, 115. It was like a little sauna rolling down the road. And we were trying in the morning every time we cut, they'd try to pump the air. But then we'd have to turn it off, and you'd only be able to work for about five, ten minutes before it became unbearable. So we got the little roly unit.
A brilliant idea. So wonderful. But then we started. moving, and my chair was right under the little sunroof. I was very excited. I was like, this is awesome. I'm going to get all the air. I'm going to get the first amazing cool air. Yes. But I... And you did. I sure did. And I was... That part is true. It was very cool. I was smelling the air as it was cooling me, and I was like, it doesn't smell right. It smells gassy. It smells not right.
Right. And so you started voicing that. Yeah. And I was more towards the front. And I was like, I don't, I don't smell anything. I don't. And there was a little bit of like, Jenna, a little bit. Well, I know. To be fair, I was the person on the set who had all the allergies and I was ruining takes from sneezing all the time. And I think people thought it was just Jenna's allergy nose, Jenna sensitive. And I was like, no, no, no, it's not that. It's like gas. And then Sarah, our camera operator, who was standing back there by you, she was like, I, like, wasn't she had a little loosy. Yeah. And then, Brian, I think you came up. I did. And you were like, let me see what you're talking about. Wait.
I stood on a chair right where your desk was, and I put my face right up to the register where the air was coming. And sure enough, carbon dioxide. Nice cold. I remember you go, get off the bus. That's right. And we all exited the bus, and that is when you can tell everyone what they discovered. Well, it was a great, great idea, but the execution was not thoroughly thought through. So what we came up with when we realized in production meeting was saying, it's going to be hot as hell on this bus.
How are we going to keep everybody from wilting? And I said, we can pull a portable air conditioning unit. that is strong enough to pump fresh air into the bus. And my concern was I want to be able to shoot toward the back so I can't see it. We can make it low enough, small enough, to where it won't be seen throughout the windows. And we thought about we'd have to adjust the rearview mirrors just, and what about the noise? And no, no, these new ones are. So we really thought about this.
我们怎么才能不让每个人都无精打采呢？我说，我们可以拉一台便携式空调，它的功率足以向公交车里输送新鲜空气。我当时担心的是，我要能朝后方拍摄，所以我希望看不到它。我们可以把它做得足够低、足够小，这样在窗户里就看不到了。我们还想过，得调整一下后视镜，还有噪音怎么办？不，不，这些新型号的可以。所以我们确实考虑过这个问题。
Okay, great, great, great. And we'll just tow it. We'll have a tow hitch on the bus. We'll hook it up and we'll just tow this unit. It has its own generator. It's quiet and perfect solution. What could go wrong? Well, what went wrong was the intake for the air conditioning unit was positioned the way it's manufactured.
好的，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。我们直接把它拖着走就行。我们在公交车上装个拖车钩。把它连上，我们就拖着这个设备。它自带发电机。它很安静，是个完美的解决方案。能出什么问题呢？好吧，出问题的是，空调的进气口是按照它出厂时的设计安装的。
And it just so happens the way it was placed on this trailer was it was facing the back of the bus. at about a foot and a half away from where this intake is is the exhaust pipe of the bus. So the fumes and exhaust from the bus only had about a foot distance away from the intake from the air conditioning. Just getting sucked up going right to the bus.
而很不巧的是，它在这个拖车上的朝向正好对着公交车尾部。离这个进气口大约一英尺半的地方就是公交车的排气管。所以公交车排出的废气和尾气距离空调进气口只有大约一英尺的距离。直接就被吸进去，全进了公交车里。
There was no possibility of avoiding this. And it was locked down, but we didn't realize that until we are actually underway. And the thing was fired up. And actually, Jenna, you and your sensitive nose saved our lives. Finally! It did some good in my life.
根本没有办法避开这一点。而且它是锁死的，但我们直到真正开动车上路才意识到这一点。设备启动了。事实上，珍娜，你那敏感的鼻子救了我们的命。总算发挥作用了！它在我生命中做了一件好事。
You saved our lives. At first, what? How can exhaust be coming inside? It just doesn't make any sense to me. Yeah. And sure enough, when I said, I went, oh, my God, we have made a huge mistake. And we nearly killed the entire cast of the office. Really incredible.
你救了我们的命。起初，什么？废气怎么会跑进车里？这简直让我无法理解。对啊。果不其然，当我说了之后，我说，哦，天哪，我们犯了一个大错误。我们差点把《办公室》整个剧组都害死了。真的太离谱了。
But I would say, had no one detected it, what a beautiful way to go. All together. Right? Oh, my God, all together. Combaya! Shibuya roll call. The big roll call. Well, Leslie, I remember looking at Leslie David Baker, and his eyes were bloodshot and watering.
不过我要说的是，如果当时没人发现，这倒也是一种绝佳的死法。大家一起。对吧？哦，天哪，一起。合唱吧！涉谷点名。大点名。好吧，莱斯利，我记得我看着莱斯利·大卫·贝克，他的眼睛充血了，还含着眼泪。
And I kept thinking, like, maybe the vent is hitting him at an angle. You know how it dries out your eyes? Like if a vent hits you, but no, it was just poison. Now, was Leslie's desk close to yours? Yes. I'm trying to remember. When we had the, when we all went flying into one another, I believe I flew into Leslie. Did this, when we got off, I remember he was like, I'm not getting back on.
我当时一直觉得，可能是风口正对着他，角度不对。你知道那种把眼睛吹干的感觉吗？就像风口一直吹着你一样，但不是，那纯粹是毒气。对了，莱斯利的办公桌离你的近吗？是的。我努力想记起来。当我们的车剧烈摇晃、大家都撞到一块儿去的时候，我好像撞到了莱斯利。下车时，我记得他说，我再也不上去了。
Leslie said I'm never getting back on the bus again. I'm done. I don't remember. I remember him walking to his car and driving away, but I think that might not be true. But for some reason, I remember Leslie was like, goodbye. I'm out. I'm out. Shoot around me.
莱斯利说我再也不上车了。我受够了。我不记得了。我记得他走向自己的车并开车走了，但我觉得这可能不是真的。不过不知为什么，我记得莱斯利当时就像是在说，再见。我走了。我走了。你们自己拍吧。
But also, poor Leslie, whenever we went on locations, he got the worst of it. When we went to the beach, he got sand kicked in his eye and it scratched his cornea and he had to wear like a patch for a week. Yeah. So I think Leslie was like, I don't do scenes outside of the office. Yeah. Forget it. Forget it. I don't go on location.
而且真可怜，莱斯利，每次我们去外景地，他总是倒大霉。当我们在海滩时，有沙子吹进他眼里，刮伤了他的角膜，他不得不戴了一周的眼罩。对。所以我想莱斯利当时的心态是，办公室之外的戏我可不拍。对。算了吧。算了吧。我不去外景地。
Yeah, shit goes down. It almost sounds like his character. You just drill, I don't go outside. Yeah, I don't leave the office. Were there any moments that you haven't talked about about this episode? Because we know you've been hit up with those questions quite a bit. But any behind-the-scenes memories that you have that you'd want to share? Yeah, those things are so on the frontal lobe that it's hard to remember.
对，总会出乱子。听起来有点像他在剧里的角色。你就直说，我不出去。对，我不离开办公室。对于这一集，有没有什么是你们还没聊过的？因为我们知道你们已经被问过很多次这些问题了。但有没有什么你很想分享的幕后回忆？对，那些事情在脑海里太深刻了，反而很难记起来。
I just had a really good time other than worrying about that. I was really happy to be able to be on your set and see it and feel it. You guys, by the time I came along, it was the ninth season, so you were a well-oiled machine. And the role of a guest director is not to come in, and I wouldn't dare, wouldn't dare say anything to an actor about their character. How, how, wouldn't that be obnoxious? Like, season nine, I think you could make a different choice for Dwight. Let's make this. I think he's friendlier.
除了担心那些事之外，我其实过得很开心。我真的很高兴能来到你们的片场，看到它并感受它。各位，等我加入的时候已经是第九季了，所以你们已经是一个运转良好的精密机器了。客串导演的角色不是来挑刺的——而且我也不敢，绝不敢对演员的角色设定指手画脚。怎么能，怎么会这样呢？那样不是很讨人嫌吗？比如第九季，我觉得你可以为德怀特做出不同的选择。我们拍这个吧。我觉得他应该更友好一点。
Yeah. Why is Angela such a bitch? What's with the cats? Let's do away with us. No more cats. No more cats. Yeah, and then you two, you know, I'd say, I'd pull you apart. Start to think about something about Jim that you didn't like.
对。安吉拉为什么这么刻薄？这满屋的猫是怎么回事？我们把猫都弄走吧。不要再养猫了。不要再养猫了。对，然后你们两个，你知道的，我会说，我会把你们拉开。开始想一些你讨厌吉姆的地方。
Yeah. Just throw a wrench into everything. He's like, I don't think this. So there's nothing, a director on episodic television just comes in and tries to, what my whole goal was, whenever I direct television, which is different from directing features because in features, it's, it's, you, you are trying and need to please yourself and make sure that you get all those elements and moments that you've worked so hard in breaking down that script. But in television, it's about staying true to these characters, putting them in positions where they can really be themselves, where they feel comfortable. It's delivering the meat and potatoes that every showrunner is going to expect from you. I always thought, if I can deliver two or three things that the showrunner didn't see, that's golden. Just a couple little, couple little things.
对。给一切都添点乱。他会说，我不这么认为。所以没别的，电视剧的分集导演就是来，我所有的目标——每当我导演电视剧时，这与导演电影不同，因为在电影中，它，它，你正在努力并且需要取悦自己，确保你获得了那些你花了那么多时间剖析剧本才挖掘出来的所有元素和精彩瞬间。但在电视剧中，关键在于忠于这些角色，把他们放在能真正展现自我的位置上，让他们感到舒适。它是交付每一个剧集统筹都对你抱有期望的硬核内容。我总是想，如果我能呈现出两三个剧集统筹没料到的东西，那就太棒了。就几个小小的，几个小小的点。
I think there's a few. I mean, when I rewatch the episode, I completely forgot that Ed plays the banjo at the end. Oh, yeah, yeah. And just rips it. It's just so great. And everyone is just like, oh, whatever. Well, no, it's, and it's true. I taught him the banjo in two weeks, and he was able to pick it up and be performed that.
我觉得有几个。我是说，当我重看这一集时，我完全忘了艾德在最后弹了班卓琴。哦，对，对。而且弹得超级赞。真是太棒了。每个人都一副，哦，随便吧的表情。好吧，不，这是，而且千真万确。我花了两周时间教他弹班卓琴，他就能上手并进行表演了。
That's amazing. Yeah. I loved all the pie scenes, too. I thought they were really sweet. Did you eat any pie? I had some pie. Do you remember your flavor of pie? That's probably hard to remember.
太厉害了。对。我也很喜欢所有的派的场景。我觉得它们真的很温馨。你吃过派吗？我吃过一些派。你还记得你吃的派是什么口味的吗？这可能有点难记。
I'm thinking Gooseberry? Yeah. Yeah. That was, look how happy you were. Well, if he remembered that. Wasn't that one? Yeah. Because it's such a funny name.
我想是醋栗味？对。对。那就是，看你当时多开心。好吧，如果他还记得的话。难道不是那个吗？对。因为这个名字太有趣了。
I like it. Yeah, there was like a, it was like a, I think it was gooseberry. Because it wasn't blackberry. No. It was, yeah, but there was a special berry crumble pie. Pie. When I rewatched it, I just remember how happy we actually all were to sit outside and have pie. Yeah.
我喜欢。对，当时有一种，那是一种，我觉得是醋栗派。因为不是黑莓。不是。那是，对，但那是一种特别的浆果酥皮派。派。当我重看这一集时，我只记得当时我们所有人坐在外面吃派是多么的高兴。对。
I had chocolate cream. It was delicious. Interesting choice on a very hot day. What? Chocolate cream. Fill back the layers. Okay. I have got to do something.
我吃的是巧克力奶油派。味道好极了。在大热天里这倒是个有趣的抉择。什么？巧克力奶油派。剥开层层面纱。好吧。我得做点什么。
I have been going through the call sheets. And on the back of the call sheet, they do a thing called get to know your casting crew. And they ask a few. questions, but they're so interesting. You mean on every one of your call sheets, it was get to know your cast and crew? Someone was featured on each call sheet. We had talked about, Jen and I wanted to start with each new guest, ask them a few of these questions.
我一直在翻看通告单。在通告单的背面，他们会做一个名为“了解你的演职人员”的栏目。他们会问几个问题，但都非常有趣。你是说在你们的每一份通告单上，都有“了解你的演职人员”这个栏目？每一份通告单上都会特色介绍一个人。我们之前讨论过，珍娜和我希望能从每位新嘉宾开始，问他们几个这样的问题。
What was one of the first jobs you had in entertainment? One of the first jobs I had in entertainment. I think it was a soap opera. I did a like a three-day role on Days of Our Lives. I love Days of Our Lives. Back in 1981. What was your character? I was a cousin of the person.
你在娱乐圈的第一份工作是什么？我在娱乐圈的第一份工作。我想那是一部肥皂剧。我在《我们的日子》里演了一个三天的角色。我超爱《我们的日子》。早在1981年。你演的是什么角色？我是某个角色的表亲。
I will tell you this. Bill and Susan Seaforth, he and his wife, Susan and Bill, they were on Days of Our Lives for years. I happened to oversleep that morning the first day that I was to work. And I missed the rehearsal, miss the blocking, missed everything. I'm panicking, absolutely panicking. And I race to NBC where we're shooting it. And I'm panicking. I'm nervous.
我跟你说这个。比尔和苏珊·西福思，他和他的妻子，苏珊和比尔，他们在《我们的日子》里演了好多年。我碰巧在那天早上我该工作的头一天睡过头了。我错过了排练，错过了走位，什么都错过了。我恐慌了，彻底恐慌了。我疯狂赶往我们拍摄的全国广播公司（NBC）。我恐慌极了。我很紧张。
And all of a sudden, I hear knocking on my dressing room door. And it's Bill Hayes, the big star of the show. Yeah. And he says, I understand you had a problem this morning. We stood in for you and we blocked it. And he says, can I run down what we did? You need some help on the back story of the character. I was so appreciative.
突然，我听到有人敲我化妆间的门。是比尔·海斯，剧中的大明星。对。他说，我听说你今天早上遇到了麻烦。我们替你顶上并完成了走位。然后他说，需要我把我们刚才做的事给你过一遍吗？你需要了解这个角色的背景故事吗？我当时太感激了。
I was just a day player. And he put himself out there to say, look. That is so kind. Yeah, he was a lovely, lovely guy. And he helped me get over the anxiety of being late and the responsibility of that. And I spent all the money that I made on that episode to buy flowers for the people that I knew stood up for me. and Bill and the casting director. And it was like, I'm so sorry.
我只是个只拍一天的临时演员。而他却主动伸出援手说，听着。太暖心了。对，他是个可爱至极的人。他帮我克服了迟到的焦虑和由此产生的责任感。我把我那一集赚的所有的钱，都用来给那些我知道替我解围的人买花了。比尔还有选角导演。当时的感觉就像是，真的非常抱歉。
But that was my, yeah, it was my first experience. Okay. I love that. I love that story. And I love the kindness you were shown. I didn't know where that was going when you said he knocked on the door. I was like, oh, no. Yeah, no.
但那是我的，对，那是我的第一次经历。好的。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个故事。我也喜欢你感受到的善意。当你刚说他敲门时，我还不知道事情会朝哪个方向发展。我当时想，噢，不。对，不是的。
In a good way. In a good way. Okay. Favorite place in the whole wide world that you've ever been to? I guess it would be Venice. I was there on my honeymoon almost 35 years ago. very romantic and very unique. And we just had, there was one night
是往好的方向发展。往好的方向发展。好吧。去过的大千世界中，你最喜欢的地方是哪里？我想大概是威尼斯吧。我差不多35年前在那里度蜜月。非常浪漫，非常独特。而且我们刚好遇到，有一天晚上
when my wife and I were, there was a thunderous rainstorm. And we went to a Vivaldi concert in a church that had windows at the top of this sphere and this dome. And it felt like God was adding the exclamation to it. Da-da-da-da-da.
我和我妻子正赶上一场雷雨。我们在一个教堂里听了一场维瓦尔第音乐会，那个教堂的这个穹顶和球体顶部开有窗户。感觉就像上帝在为它加上叹号一样。哒-哒-哒-哒-哒。
You know, and oh my God, it was just so, it was just so magical and romantic, unbelievable time. Wow. Have you been back since your honeymoon? Actually, no, it's been a long time. I've been there twice. We haven't been back in 34 years. It's time to go back. I think it's time. Yeah. I don't know. I say don't mess with it. What? I say leave it. Don't revisit? Never revisit a memory.
你知道的，哦天哪，真的是太神奇了，太浪漫了，无与伦比的时光。哇。你自度蜜月之后再去过吗？其实没有，已经过去很久了。我去过那里两次。我们已经34年没回去了。是时候回去了。我觉得是时候了。对。我不知道。我说别去破坏它。什么？我说顺其自然吧。不去重游？永远不要去重游一段记忆。
Well, it's too good. It's too good. You know what I mean? If you go back and then you're going to be like, oh, my gosh, it smells. I mean, no offense, Venice, but I hear that you're getting floods and maybe it's a little stinky now. Here come the tourists. Here come the letters. The cruise ships and the...
好吧，它太美好了。太美好了。你知道我的意思吗？如果你回去，然后你就会想，哦，天哪，这里有异味。我是说，无意冒犯，威尼斯，但我听说你们那里经常发水，现在可能有点臭了。游客大军来了。旅行团的信件来了。游轮和……
All the Venetians. I've lost the whole... The amount of gondoliers that listen to the show. It's just incredible. We just lost a few. Well, I'm just saying, you know, a lot of time has passed, and this isn't a... amazing romantic memory. Maybe it should just stay there. I agree with you. I agree with you maybe in the church, in the concert, in the rain and all that. But I don't think you need to
所有的威尼斯人。我已经失去了整整……听节目的贡多拉船夫的数量。简直难以置信。我们刚刚失去了一些听众。好吧，我只是说，你知道的，已经过去了很长时间，这不是一段……惊人的浪漫回忆。也许它就应该停留在那里。我同意你的看法。也许在教堂里，在音乐会中，在雨中以及所有那些时刻，我同意你的看法。但我觉得你没必要
rule out all of Venice. I think there's maybe new places you could discover. Yeah. I think leave it. Okay. Well, I'm torn now. Two very different takes on this memory. Okay. Last question. They just asked three. Last question, do you speak any other languages other than English? We. We? Oh, ho. I don't, actually. That was the extent of my French.
把整个威尼斯都排除在外。我觉得也许有你可以发掘的新地方。对。我觉得还是留在记忆里吧。好吧。我现在纠结了。对这段记忆有两种截然不同的看法。好的。最后一个问题。他们只问了三个。最后一个问题，除了英语，你还会说其他语言吗？威。威？哦，吼。其实不会。那就是我的法语水平的极限了。
No, I know a little bit of French and a little bit of Spanish. But that's one of the things I really, really do want to accomplish before I leave this earth, is to be able to expand my awareness and culture and not just be so American-centric. You know, I want to step out of it. of that. I spoke recently about not retiring, but taking a break. For the last 25 years, I've been working really nonstop. And it's been great. As we know, it's wonderful. And, you know, you're supported and you're having fun and you're engaged and it's artistic and creative and all those wonderful things. But it's not real life experience. You're going from one bubble to
不，我懂一点法语和一点西班牙语。但这是我在离开这个世界之前非常、非常想完成的事情之一，那就是拓展我的认知和文化，而不只是那么以美国为中心。你知道，我想跳出那个圈子。我最近谈到了不退休，而是休息一段时间。在过去的25年里，我真的在马不停蹄地工作。而且感觉很棒。如我们所知，这很美妙。而且，你知道的，你得到了支持，你在享受乐趣，你全身心投入，它是富有艺术性和创造性的以及所有这些美好的事物。但这并不是真实的现实生活体验。你从一个气泡走到
another bubble to another bubble. And I'm getting to a point where I feel like I'm a little depleted. Like my ideas aren't as fresh. They're a little harder to come by. And ooh, am I being derivative of another character that I've done? And can I break out of that? I needed more, I need more influences to come in so that it's more reciprocal. Right now, there's been a lot of outflow for the last two decades. And I think I need some real life experience to be able to say, oh, I've never even thought of that before. I want to read that classic novel that I've always sworn I was going to read. I want to learn how to cook. I want to learn a language. I want to be in another culture. And I don't want to talk about show business. Yeah. We had an amazing
另一个气泡，再到另一个气泡。我开始觉得有些筋疲力尽了。好像我的想法不再那么新鲜了。它们有点难得到了。噢，我是不是在重复我以前塑造过的另一个角色？我能打破这种局限吗？我需要更多的影响注入进来，这样才能形成更多的双向交流。目前，在过去的二十家里，输出的东西实在太多了。我想我需要一些现实的生活体验，才能说，哦，我以前从来没有这样想过。我想读那本我一直发誓要读的经典小说。我想学做饭。我想学一门语言。我想去体验另一种文化。我不想再谈论娱乐圈了。对。我们有过一次精彩的
conversation with Zach Woods, and we were talking about this exact thing where we were saying that as artists, you need a life to feed your art. You can't stay in just an art-making bubble. No. Because it's through our observations of other people and things, and it's through going to that weird cousin's wedding that you get your ideas and your inspiration. And I would extend to that even to, I remember Jerry Seinfeld doing an interview about this, talking about how much of his comedy comes from the frustrations and little annoyances in his life of standing in a line or someone, you know, budding in front of you as you're been waiting for a lot, you know, all those little ways that you watch how different people handle these everyday, very universal
对话，对象是扎克·伍兹，我们讨论的正是这件事，我们当时说，作为艺术家，你需要生活来滋养你的艺术。你不能只呆在一个制造艺术的气泡里。没错。因为正是通过我们对其他人和事的观察，正是通过去参加那个古怪表亲的婚礼，你才获得了想法和灵感。我甚至想把这一点延伸到——我记得杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）做过一个关于这方面的采访，谈到他的喜剧有多少来自于生活中的挫折和小烦恼，比如排队时遇到有人插队，或者你在等某个东西时有人插到你前面，你知道的，所有这些你观察不同的人如何处理这些日常的、非常普遍的
situations. They inform you. They inform your art. And like you said, when you go from set to set to set or bubble to bubble, you start losing all those. And those are the things that we use to make our characters. I used to joke that I haven't changed. I've had great good fortune in this business, but I really haven't changed. My dresser still puts on my pants one leg at a time.
情况的小细节。它们启迪了你。它们启迪了你的艺术。就像你说的，当你从一个片场转到另一个片场，或者从一个气泡到另一个气泡时，你开始失去所有这些东西。而这些正是我们用来塑造角色的素材。我过去常开玩笑说，我没有变。我在这个行业里运气很好，但我真的没变。我的服装师仍然是一条腿套一条腿地帮我穿裤子。
Good. He really does. You're a good job. You're valid. It's my valet. You're valid. I traveled a lot growing up. My dad was a drilling engineer. I grew up in Jakarta, and we moved around a lot. But recently, I found an old travel journal that I kept as a young gal. And I read a little bit of it on the podcast. I was very snarky about a man who sat next to me who was taking a lot of notes about how to play poker on his napkin, but he would cover them so I couldn't see him. And I was like, what's up with this guy? And I was like, what's up with this guy? And I had a whole journal of paper, and I would have given him a piece of paper, but he kept hiding his notes, so I didn't.
太棒了。他真的会这样。你干得不错。你很有价值。他是我的贴身男仆。你很有价值。我成长过程中经常旅行。我爸爸是一名钻井工程师。我在雅加达长大，我们经常搬家。但最近，我找到了一本我年轻时保留的旧旅行日记。我在播客上读了一小段。对于一个坐在我旁边、在餐巾纸上密密麻麻记着怎么玩扑克牌的笔记、却又遮遮掩掩不让我看的男人，我表现得非常尖酸刻薄。我当时想，这家伙怎么回事？我当时想，这家伙到底在搞什么鬼？我有一整本纸质日记，我本可以分给他一张纸的，但他一直藏着他的笔记，所以我没给。
It was like this weird, like retaliation I had with him. But the story has a point, which is, as I go back and look at that journal of travel and seeing other things and experiencing other things, I just crave it. And like, I want to sit next to the guy on the plane who is taking notes on his napkin. What's that about? Now, what's interesting, though, is that now you have to hope that you're not recognized in order to have a legitimate conversation. Otherwise, it's weighted. Yeah. And it's not the same thing.
这就好像我和他之间有一种奇怪的、报复性的互动。但这个故事的重点是，当我回过头去翻看那本记录旅行、见证其他事物并体验其他事物的日记时，我简直渴望极了。而且，我想坐在飞机上那个在餐巾纸上做笔记的家伙旁边。那是什么情况？不过，现在有趣的是，你必须寄希望于自己不被认出来，才能进行一次真正的对话。否则，对话就会变得有功利色彩。对。那就不是一回事了。
Celebrity is a strange thing, as we know. It makes people nervous, anxious, giddy, excited. They can't stop. They can't believe it. I mean, how many people have said, I can't believe I'm meeting you. It's blowing my mind. Well, that's not the way that person normally behaves. Yeah.
名人效应是一件奇怪的事，正如我们所知。它让人神经紧张、焦虑、飘飘然、兴奋不已。他们停不下来。他们简直不敢相信。我是说，有多少人说过，我不敢相信我正在见你。我简直要惊呆了。好吧，那可不是那个人平时的正常行为。对。
So there's no way that you're going to have a normal conversation with that person. So I always used to look for old people. If I were in a – some people who didn't know – chances are, wouldn't know who I am. And that way, I knew I was getting an authentic conversation. Oh, yeah. Didn't I mean? I do. I do.
所以你根本不可能跟那种人进行正常的对话。所以我以前总是去找老年人。如果我在一个——有些人不认识——大概不会知道我是谁。通过这种方式，我知道我得到的是一场真实的对话。哦，是的。难道不是吗？我确实这么觉得。我确实这么觉得。
I do. One of my favorite cities is New York, and one of my favorite things to do is just people watch. And so I love to go hide out in Central Park and just watch everything unfold in front of me. And that's something I find you can still go unrecognized. And if you wear your hat and you don't make a big fuss about yourself. And your big red nose. Yes, that's right. And your floppy shoes. And my wig. And then I smoke. You know, we know I don't smoke in real life. Start making balloon animals. They won't know who you are. I feel the same way when I go to my family has a farm in Archer City, Texas, and there's a little cafe, Merns, because the woman who runs it is named Mern. Fantastic. And, you know, it's great.
我确实这么觉得。我最喜欢的城市之一是纽约，我最喜欢做的事情之一就是观察人群。所以我喜欢去中央公园躲起来，静静地看着身边的这一切上演。而这也是我发现你仍然可以不被认出来的事情。只要你戴上帽子，而且别太把自己当回事。还有你那标志性的大红鼻子。对，没准。还有你那宽大的鞋子。还有我的假发。然后我抽烟。你知道的，我们都知道我现实生活中不抽烟。开始表演折气球动物。他们就不知道你是谁了。当我回——我家人在德克萨斯州阿彻市有一个农场，那里有一家小咖啡馆，叫默恩斯（Merns），因为经营它的女人叫默恩。棒极了。而且，你知道的，那感觉太好了。
I go in there, and it's just everyone that's been working cattle, and they're all in there. And it's, I just love it. No one knows the show. Do they have your picture? up on the wall. They don't. No, they have like, come on, Mern. They have the starting lineup of the football team and the cheerleaders and whoever is, you know, doing well at 4-H club that year. It's, um... That's rather sweet. Yeah, it is. It's great. I used to travel a lot by motorcycle. In the 70s, I traveled across the country. For two years, I was on a motorcycle. Wow.
我走进去，里面全都是刚干完农活的牧牛人，他们全都在那儿。而且，我简直爱死那儿了。没人知道那个节目。他们把你的照片挂在墙上了吗？没有。不，他们挂的是橄榄球队的首发阵容、啦啦队队员，还有当年在4-H俱乐部（注：美国青少年组织）表现出色的人的照片。这，呃……这挺温馨的。对，确实如此。太棒了。我以前经常骑摩托车旅行。在70年代，我骑车横跨过全国。我有两年时间都在骑摩托车。哇。
And I would get odd jobs here and there. And in the 70s, you could do that. You ladies wouldn't know then. How do you know? Because you were way too young. And at one time I took Route 66 from California, Santa Monica, to Chicago. And on the way back, I took this Route 50, which is called the loneliest highway. And you go through Nebraska, Kansas, the places that people, for the most part, they go, well, there's nothing really to see there, so I want to avoid it. I want to go there.
我会在各个地方打打零工。在70年代，你是可以做到的。你们这些女士那时候还小，可能不知道。你怎么知道的？因为你们太年轻了。有一次我沿着66号公路从加利福尼亚圣莫尼卡开到芝加哥。在回程的路上，我走了50号公路，被称为最孤独的公路。你要穿过内布拉斯加州、堪萨斯州，那些大多数人会说“那儿真没什么可看的，所以我得绕开它”的地方。我偏要去那里。
So we were going through Kansas in a little place called Peabody, Kansas, and it's flat, it's small, there's a bank on the corner, there's a coffee shop, and in the coffee shop they list everybody's birthday for that day. And I said, these are the people who work here? And I go, no, that's people in the entire town. We have such a small town that they list everyone's birthday on that particular day. It's really, and it's quaint and sweet. And by the way, speaking of birthdays, We share a birthday. Share a birthday. You do, your birthday buddies. We are. We interviewed Tim Meadows for the podcast, and we were all talking about our celebrity birthday partner, and I said you. Yes.
所以我们当时正穿过堪萨斯州一个叫皮博迪（Peabody）的小地方，那里地势平坦，规模很小，街角有一家银行，有一家咖啡馆，而在咖啡馆里，他们列出了每个人当天的生日。我说，这是在这里工作的人吗？他们说，不，那是整个镇上的人。我们镇太小了，所以他们把每个人特定那一天的生日都列在上面。真的很古怪，也很温馨。顺便说一句，说到生日，我们俩同一天生日。同一天生日。是的，你们是生日好搭档。我们是的。我们为播客采访了蒂姆·梅多斯（Tim Meadows），我们都在谈论我们的名人生日搭档，我说的是你。是的。
I know. Happy birthday. Well, not yet. March 7th. March 7th. Yeah. Same year? Yes, 74.
我知道。生日快乐。好吧，还没到呢。3月7日。3月7日。对。同年？是的，74年。
Yeah, that's right. This is my big 50th. birthday this year. Are you welcoming it? It's going to come whether you want to or not, but I am welcoming it. You're saying, bring it on, world. Yeah, I'm saying bring it on. I'm doing big party. I'm happy to celebrate my 50th. I'm excited about it. I find it very liberating. I think it's great. You look fantastic. You both look great. I am 52. I will be 53. I love my 50s. I I love it. I told you it's the zero-fs. It's my zero-fs chapter of my life. Yeah. Super fun. I guess if it was truly my zero-fs, I'd say zero-f-hs, right? We like to keep it clean on office. We do. We keep it clean. We have a lot of young listeners. Yeah. I'll bet you do. We do. The age range is like really big. There's rumor. You probably already talked about it. There's rumor of doing a reboot. Yes, we hear Greg is working on something. Yeah, he's cooking something up.
对，没错。今年是我50岁的大寿。你欢迎它的到来吗？不管你想不想，它都会来，但我很欢迎。你是说，放马过来吧，世界。对，我说放马过来吧。我要办个盛大的派对。我很高兴庆祝我的50岁生日。我对此感到很兴奋。我觉得这非常解脱。我觉得太棒了。你看起来状态极佳。你们俩看起来都很棒。我52岁了。我马上53岁了。我爱我的50多岁。我我超爱。我告诉过你，这是“零操心”阶段。这是我人生的“零操心”章节。对。超级有趣。我想如果这真的是我的“零操心”，我会说“零操心指数”，对吧？我们在《办公室》里喜欢保持干净。是的。我们保持干净。我们有很多年轻听众。对。我敢打赌你们确实有。我们确实有。年龄跨度真的很大。有传言。你可能已经聊过了。有传言说要拍重启版。是的，我们听说格雷格在筹备什么。对，他在酝酿一些新东西。
But it's not involving the same cast. We should say that. Yeah. But I would love to pop on as a guest. Ooh, me too. I'd love to be a guest on some sort of... Next-gen office. Yeah, or something like that.
但不是原班人马。我们应该说明这一点。对。但我很乐意作为嘉宾客串一下。哦，我也是。我也很想去客串某种……新一代的《办公室》。对，诸如此类的。
That would be great. But I don't see bringing Pam back in a sort of permanent way and following her life again. At least it hasn't... But, you know, Greg Daniels is a person who could think it up and pitch it to me and get me on board. So, but I can't think of it. Right. Yeah. You know.
那会很棒。但我不认为让帕姆以某种永久的方式回归并再次追踪她的生活是个好主意。至少目前还没有……但是，你知道的，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）是一个能够构思出这个点子、向我推销并让我加入的人。所以，但我自己想不出来。对。你知道的。
So if Dunder Mifflin still existed, there'd be other people working there. Maybe. We think Creed would still be there. Creed would still be there. Brian and Oscar and I are a little accounting clump. We used to have this pitch that we would be the spinoffs, but it would be on telemundo, and it'd be like, Los Acquantadores, Oscar, Anhella, and Kevin. And I would do that. I would do the telemundo reboot of the accounts.
所以如果邓德米夫林公司还在的话，会有其他人在这儿工作。也许吧。我们觉得克里德（Creed）肯定还在那儿。克里德肯定还在。布赖恩、奥斯卡和我是一个小会计团伙。我们以前有个设想，就是我们会成为衍生剧的主角，但会在特莱维视（Telemundo）电视台播出，名字就像是《会计师们》（Los Acquantadores），奥斯卡、安吉拉和凯文。我绝对会演那个。我会演会计师们的特莱维视重启版。
Telemundo. Telemundo. Brian, what do you get approached about the most? Breaking Bad. Breaking Bad. Yeah. Yeah. Still.
特莱维视。特莱维视。布赖恩，大家找你聊得最多的角色是什么？《绝命毒师》。《绝命毒师》。对。对。依然是。
I guess the most fervent fan base. Do you get pictures of people on Halloween dressed as Walter White? All the time. All the time. Yeah, we get that too. Yeah. It's a crazy thing. You get pictures of Walter White for Halloween?
我猜是最热烈的粉丝群体。你会收到万圣节时别人打扮成沃尔特·怀特（Walter White）的照片吗？经常收到。经常收到。对，我们也收到过。对。太疯狂了。万圣节时你会收到沃尔特·怀特的照片？
I do. I do. Yeah. People want me to know. She holds a cat. Yeah. My Walter White. That's a crazy thing to have been on a show that endures.
我会的。我会的。对。人们希望我知道。她抱着一只猫。对。我的沃尔特·怀特。能参演一部经久不衰的剧集，真的是一件很疯狂的事。
I just rewatched Breaking Bad. I got COVID, and it was my COVID comfort show. I, let's see. I watched it during the pandemic. This was my rewatch, because it is my opinion that Breaking Bad is the single greatest television pilot ever. I stand by that statement. And I have loved rewatching it. And people still rewatch it, right?
我刚刚又重温了《绝命毒师》。我得了新冠，这部剧成了我的新冠慰藉剧。我，让我想想。我在大流行期间看了它。这是我的二刷，因为在我看来，《绝命毒师》是史上最棒的电视剧试播集。我坚持这个观点。我非常喜欢重温它。而且大家现在还在重温它，对吧？
And people still rewatch the office. And it's such a cool thing to be part of something that endures like that. I think it's truly legendary shows we're both all very fortunate to be chosen to be on such a thing and as people have always asked you I'm sure that always asked me did you know it was going to be a big hit and I go no it was a job we we we we we were happy to read this great script you two were like this sounds crazy this sounds yeah fun I don't know exactly how it's going to work or And let me ask you this, on the first year of the office, what were the ratings like? I mean, was it horrible. Our first season was six episodes. And we were going to get shit-cant. For sure.
而且大家现在还在重温《办公室》。能成为这样一部经久不衰的作品的一部分，真的是一件很酷的事。我认为这些都是真正传奇的剧集，我们俩所有人都非常幸运，能被选中出演这样一部作品。正如大家一直问你的，我相信他们也总是问我：“你们当时知道它会大火吗？”而我会回答：“不，这只是一份工作，我们当时很高兴能读到这个精彩的剧本。”你们俩当时的感觉就像是：“这听起来太疯狂了，听起来，对，挺有趣的。”我不太确定它究竟会怎样运作。让我问你这个，《办公室》第一季的收视率怎么样？我是说，是不是很糟糕？我们的第一季只有六集。而且我们肯定会被炒鱿鱼。
We were going to get canceled. But then that summer, between season one and deciding if we would get picked up for season two, the 40-year-old virgin came out. And Steve Corell became a massive box office comedy star. And I think NBC was like, I'm sorry, you don't. cut loose, the number one comedy box office star, you pick up that show. It was still only a little bit, not a full season for season two. And Phyllis and I used to call the ratings hotline. We used to run on Tuesday. This is how old we are. Old tech alert. Ratings hotline, may I help you? Yeah. We would run on Tuesdays originally. Before we moved to must-see TV,
我们当时肯定会被砍掉。但就在那个夏天，在第一季结束和决定我们是否会被续订第二季之间，《四十岁的老处男》上映了。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔成了票房大卖的喜剧明星。我想NBC当时的想法是：“抱歉，你不能放走这个票房第一的喜剧明星，你得续订这部剧。”第二季其实也只有短短几集，并不是一个完整的季度。我和菲莉丝过去常常打收视率热线。我们会在周二打。这就是我们的年龄。老旧科技警报。收视率热线，有什么可以帮您的？是的。我们最初是在周二播出。在我们转到“必看电视”之前，
we were on Tuesdays and every Wednesday morning, we would get on set and Phyllis and I would listen to the recording, and we knew that as long as we had like a 2.4 or above, we still had jobs. And we would just hold our breath and wait for the recording to tell us what our ratings were. Yeah. Yeah. And it was like that for into the second season. Every week I would send out a mass email. I was like that person.
我们是在周二播出，每周三早上，我们一到片场，我和菲莉丝就会听录音，我们知道只要收视率达到2.4或以上，我们就有工作。我们就会屏住呼吸，等待录音告诉我们收视率是多少。对。对。第二季的时候也是这样。每周我都会群发一封电子邮件。我就是那种人。
I was like, hey, you guys, can you guys please watch our show this week? I really mean a lot. Thanks so much. Everyone I knew from all my improv days, all my theater days. everyone back home. And then finally, it was around the first Christmas episode, Yankee Swap. One of my friends wrote back and said, I don't think you need to send these anymore. You're going to be okay.
我当时就像是：“嘿，伙计们，这周你们能看我们的节目吗？对我真的很重要。非常感谢。”我所有即兴表演日子的认识的人，我所有戏剧日子的认识的人。老家的每个人。然后最后，大约是在第一个圣诞节特辑《洋基换物》的时候。我的一个朋友回信说：“我觉得你不用再发这些了。你们会没事的。”
You're being a little annoyed. Yeah. I stopped sending me these emails. What about was Breaking Bad big in the ratings at first? No, not at all. No, we're on a cable channel AMC. We didn't, we weren't big hits. at all, although the, like, the, the critics really, really loved us.
你有点烦人了。对。别再给我发这些电子邮件了。话说回来，《绝命毒师》一开始的收视率很高吗？没有，一点也不高。没有，我们在有线电视台AMC播出。我们根本算不上大热门，不过，评论界真的非常非常喜欢我们。
So we had that, but that doesn't equate to being commercially successful. Yeah. What happened for us was a stroke of really good fortune, and that was, in 2009, Netflix switched from the red envelopes where they would send you the movies at once away. Remember the mail them to you? Sure. to streaming to where you can push a button on a computer. It changed technology.
所以我们有这一点，但这并不等同于商业上的成功。对。对我们来说，发生了一件运气极好的事，那就是在2009年，Netflix从那种会把电影一次性寄给你的红信封模式。还记得他们把它们寄给你吗？当然。转向了流媒体，你可以直接在电脑上按一个按钮。它改变了技术。
It changed availability. And Breaking Bad second season, we had two seasons. And we're like, I don't know if it's going to go a third. And maybe we'll let them go at third. And all of a sudden, everybody started to go, was able to go back and watch the first episode and then just start watching them all. And then that's what caught on. And so really it was Netflix that was the stroke of good luck for us.
它改变了获取方式。《绝命毒师》第二季，我们拍了两个季度。我们在想：“我不知道它会不会拍第三季。也许我们会让他们拍第三季。”突然之间，每个人都开始去，能够回去观看第一集，然后开始连续观看所有剧集。然后这就是大火的原因。所以真正对我们来说带来好运的是Netflix。
For us, too, kind of. Yeah. It's why we've endured since the show went off the air. Let me ask you this because I seem to remember this, and I'm not completely positive. But when Ricky Jervais's version of the original office, his character was caustic and mean-spirited and rude and biting and all those things, And Steve's character, when it first started, had more of a flavor of an edge to him, didn't it? Yeah. When I first started watching, it was more of like, ooh, and I think at some point, and I'm asking, as a fan, at what point did they go, well, let's make a, let's turn the dial on this a little bit and give him more of that confident, imbecile.
对我们来说也是，某种程度上。是的。这也是为什么自从这部剧停播后我们依然能经久不衰的原因。让我问你这个，因为我好像还记得，我不是百分之百确定。但是当瑞奇·热维斯版本的原版《办公室》里，他的角色是尖酸刻薄、刻薄无礼、尖锐刺骨以及所有这些时，史蒂夫的角色刚开始的时候，是不是更有棱角一点？是的。我刚开始看的时候，更有一种“噢”的感觉，而且我想在某个时候，我是以粉丝的身份在问，他们在哪个时刻决定：“好吧，让我们稍微调整一下转盘，赋予他更多那种自信的、白痴般的”
kind of level and not mean-spirited. That happened in that transition from season one to season two. I think, you know, people saw this lovable quality to his character in 40-year-old Virgin, and they also just started writing the show more to Steve and less to the template that Ricky had laid down with his character of David Brent. And so there was a little bit of a retooling. But we also got some really good advice from Ricky Jervais who said, hey, you know, in America, you guys like to do hundreds of episodes of shows. And David Brent doesn't work for hundreds of episodes. Like, you can't, like, have that character do this for that long. So you're going to need to find more layers to your lead character or he's going to burn out.
这种层面的特质，而不是尖酸刻薄？这发生在从第一季到第二季的转变中。我想，你知道的，人们在《四十岁的老处男》中看到了他身上这种讨人喜欢的特质，而且他们也开始更多地为史蒂夫写剧本，而不是拘泥于瑞奇为大卫·布伦特这个角色设定的模板。所以进行了一些微调。但我们也从瑞奇·热维斯那里得到了一些非常好的建议，他说：“嘿，你知道的，在美利坚，你们喜欢把剧集拍成几百集。而大卫·布伦特不适合拍几百集。听着，你不能让那个角色这么做那么长时间。”所以你需要为你的主角找到更多的层次，否则他会精疲力竭的。
And also. So true. So true. So smart. The writer's room also did something that I thought really worked for American audience. audiences is each episode has one redeeming moment. One moment where it's either Pam listening to Jim's messages as she drives home and there's a montage or it's, you know, Dwight getting a pat on the shoulder from Michael, even though the whole day they were like fighting. There's one little moment. And it doesn't have to be a huge one, but each episode has one. So you're saying that this was a
而且也是。太对了。太对了。太聪明了。编剧室还做了一件事，我认为这非常适合美国观众。观众的特点是，每一集都有一个救赎的高光时刻。某一个时刻，要么是潘在开车回家的路上听着吉姆的留言，同时有一个蒙太奇；要么是，你知道的，德怀特得到了迈克尔拍拍肩膀的鼓励，尽管他们整天都在争吵。只有一个小小的时刻。它不需要很大，但每一集都有这样一个时刻。所以你是说这是一个
a concerted effort, this was a note that every episode we want to have at least one redeeming quality come out of it. Yeah, one moment. A moment of hope. One moment of hope. A moment of Zen. Yes. Look at that.
这是一次刻意的努力，这是一个记号，即每一集我们都希望至少有一个救赎的特质从中体现出来？是的，一个时刻。一个充满希望的时刻。一个充满希望的时刻。一个禅意的时刻。是的。你看。
I didn't know that. Yeah. And if you, now if I go back and watch, I tell, I see it. I can find them. I'm like, oh, well, that kind of made me feel better about that to that work bus day. We got to have pie. We got to sit outside. Was that our moment?
我当时不知道。是的。如果你，现在如果我回去看，我告诉，我看到了。我能找到它们。我会想：“噢，好吧，这让我对那辆工作巴士的一天感觉好了一些。”我们得吃派。我们得坐在外面。那是我们的时刻吗？
Yeah. We got pie at the end? Yeah, the montage at the end of pie. Well, there's another moment in this episode that I actually love, which is Jim and Dwight up on the roof of the bus. Oh, yes. And I love any moment when, you know, that these rivals, these guys who are always, you know, Jim's always pranking Dwight and everything. But when there's this moment where Dwight gets vulnerable and Jim is there to catch him. And I love that.
对。我们最后吃到了派？对，结尾吃派的蒙太奇。嗯，这一集里还有另一个时刻我真的很喜欢，那就是吉姆和德怀特坐在巴士的屋顶上。噢，是的。我喜欢任何这样的时刻，你知道的，这些竞争对手，这些总是，你知道的，吉姆总是在捉弄德怀特等等。但当出现这样一个时刻，德怀特变得脆弱，而吉姆就在那里接住他。我喜欢那个。
That was a really beautiful scene. That's true, because that exposes the audience to the true character of Jim. And that he's, when it's necessary, when someone expresses vulnerability like that, it's like he doesn't come in for the kill. Yeah. He backs off and actually lend support. Oh. Oh, see? It's very sweet.
那真的是一个非常美丽的场景。确实如此，因为这向观众暴露了吉姆真实的性格。而且他是，当有必要的时候，当有人表现出这种脆弱时，他并不是来置对方于死地的。是的。他退后了一步，实际上给予了支持。噢。噢，看？这非常甜蜜。
I had a few moments like that. You know, we kind of, I mean, so let's say that there's not a reboot series, but what if there was like a movie? Like Downton Abbey, the movie? Yeah, something to where we can see where these people are, these people in the entire cast that were curious about. We wondered at the end, where did they go? What did become of them? I mean, I'd do it. I would do it.
我有过几个这样的时刻。你知道的，我们某种程度上，我是说，假设没有重启系列，但如果是一部电影呢？就像《唐顿庄园》大电影那样？是的，某种能让我们看到这些人在哪里，这些我们很好奇的演员阵容里的所有人的地方。我们在结局时想知道，他们去哪里了？他们后来怎么样了？我是说，我会演的。我会演的。
I would do it for my kids, because I think they would think that's fun. I mean, if Greg did it, because I would trust it, you know, yes, 100%. For sure. Greg is signed on in this hypothetical. Okay, as long as Greg is writing it and he's in charge of it, then I say yes. Okay. Enough said. Brian Cranston.
我会为了我的孩子们演，因为我觉得他们会觉得这很有趣。我是说，如果格雷格来拍的话，因为我会信任它，你知道的，是的，百分之百。肯定的。在这个假设中，格雷格已经签约了。好吧，只要格雷格在写剧本并且由他掌舵，那我就会说好。好吧。无需多言。布莱恩·克兰斯顿。
Let's get Greg on the phone. He's our new agent. I just want to be, I just want to be an extra in it. I do. You have to be in it. I would be an extra in it. I would be some guy. I'd be like a crossing guard or something like that.
我们把格雷格叫来。他是我们的新经纪人。我只想成为，我只想在里面演一个龙套。我是认真的。你必须参演。我会在里面演一个龙套。我会演某个路人甲。我会像是个交通协管员或者类似的角色。
Maybe you're like one of Dwight's hired hands on troop farms. On his farm. Now, why would I be the hired hand and not the foreman? Thank you. It's just how we see you. It would be sad. It's like, look at that old guy. He's just a hired hand.
也许你就像是德怀特在施鲁特农场雇用的长工之一。在他的农场。那为什么我是长工而不是工头呢？谢谢。这就是我们看你的方式。那会很悲哀。就像是：“看那个老头。他只是个长工。”
Why's he happened to like bail hay? He's an old man and they're making him bail hay. Oh, that's not right. That's not the moment. a Zen. That's not a nice moment at all. Are there any projects you're working on right now that we can share with our listeners? We know you're working on the project of living life. Yes. The project of living life? That's a good way to put it. I really do need to do that. I'm very fortunate that I'm in a position where I'm getting a lot of offers, both for theater and films and television
为什么他偏偏要搬干草？他是个老头，他们却让他搬干草。噢，这不对。这不是那个时刻。禅意。这根本不是一个美好的时刻。你们现在有什么正在进行的项目可以和我们的听众分享吗？我们知道你正在进行“生活”这个项目。是的。生活这个项目？这倒是个好说法。我确实需要这样做。我很幸运，我现在的处境让我能接到很多邀约，无论是戏剧、电影还是电视
and things. And so I just have to pick and choose what is new to me and challenging. I don't want to do something that I've done before. Yeah. And the more I go without that real life experience, the harder that is to find
以及各种项目。所以我只需要精挑细选出对我来说是全新的、具有挑战性的东西。我不想重复我以前做过的事。是的。而且我缺乏这种现实生活经验的时间越长，那就越难找到
because I haven't changed. It's like you were saying. Like if a band just played the same music over and over and they never expanded, they never wrote beyond what they were. Like, you look at the Beatles and they weren't together all that long, but they expanded and expressed themselves in so many different ways. Whatever they were going through, it was infused in their art. And I kind of want to, I want to do that.
因为我没有变。就像你刚才说的。就像一支乐队如果只是一遍又一遍地演奏相同的音乐，而从不拓展，从不创作超越他们自身的东西。你看披头士乐队，他们在一起的时间其实并不长，但他们拓展并以如此多的不同方式表达了自己。无论他们经历了什么，都融入到了他们的艺术中。我某种程度上想，我想做到这一点。
I want to, I want to get out of the bubble a little bit. So that's that. But before that may happen, there's responsibilities I have. I have a mescal company with Aaron Paul, those sombris. Oh, wow. Yeah. And had I been a great guess, I would have brought you some. Damn it.
我想，我想稍微跳出这个舒适圈。所以就是这样。但在那之前可能会发生的事情是，我还有责任。我和亚伦·保尔有一个梅斯卡尔酒品牌，Dos Hombres。噢，哇。是的。如果我是个好嘉宾的话，我本该带点给你们的。该死。
I forgot. But that's going well. It's this business I've never thought I'd be in. We'll share about it in our office ladies' pod stories. It's so good. It's so good. Did you get to go, like, do a tasting? Did you get to be part of the formula?
我给忘了。但进展顺利。这是我从未想过自己会涉足的行业。我们会在我们的“办公室女士”播客故事里分享这件事。太棒了。太棒了。你有去，比如说，做品酒吗？你有参与配方的制定吗？
Yeah. How does that work? Yeah. Well, here's Aaron and I. three years after the end of Breaking Band, we missed each other. And, you know, it's like when you leave. We can relate. Yeah.
是的。那是怎么运作的？是的。好吧，事情是这样的，亚伦和我。在《绝命毒师》结束三年后，我们都很想念彼此。而且，你知道的，就像当你离开。我们能感同身受。是的。
And you're together, you're together, you're together. It ends and life goes on and sends you in different directions. And we happen to be in New York City at the same time. And we have to have dinner. So we're having dinner. And we expressed how much we missed each other. And he said, you know, we ought to do is have a company. We ought to have a mescal company together.
然后你们在一起，你们在一起，你们在一起。结束了，生活继续，把你们带向不同的方向。我们碰巧同时在纽约市。我们必须吃个晚饭。所以我们在吃晚饭。我们表达了我们有多么想念彼此。他说：“你知道的，我们应该合伙开个公司。我们应该一起开个梅斯卡尔酒公司。”
What? That's what I said. I go, what do you? That's random. That's terrible. That shitty spirit with a dead worm at the bottom out of, what are you talking about? And he goes, no, no, no, no. He took me to a mescal bar in New York City.
什么？我当时就是这么说的。我说：“你什么意思？”这太随机了。这太糟糕了。那种劣质的烈酒，瓶底还泡着一条死虫子，你在说什么呢？他说：“不，不，不，不。”他带我去了纽约市的一家梅斯卡尔酒吧。
We sipped some of the greatest spirits that I've ever had. I don't think I've ever had mescal. Oh, so good. It's a, it's the older brother of tequila. Okay. Tequila is a mescal. Okay. But mescal is not a tequila.
我们品尝了我喝过的最棒的一些烈酒。我想我以前从来没喝过梅斯卡尔。噢，太棒了。它是，它是龙舌兰酒的亲哥哥。好吧。龙舌兰酒是一种梅斯卡尔。好吧。但梅斯卡尔不全是龙舌兰酒。
A spirit like that that's made from an agave plant is always a mescal. And the way they make tequila is to steam it and put it in a silo and it's more of a fast process. Mescal is smoked. And so it's in an earthen pit for four days and then mashed. In fact, ours, we have, it says artisanol on the bottle and there's no modern technology used in the process of this, or else we can't say that on the bottle. Wow. So it's the old-fashioned way.
像那种由龙舌兰植物制成的烈酒总是被称为梅斯卡尔。他们制作龙舌兰酒的方法是将其蒸熟并放入筒仓中，这是一个更快的工艺。梅斯卡尔是烟熏的。所以它要在土坑里放四天，然后再捣碎。事实上，我们的酒，瓶子上写着“手工制作”，在这个过程中没有使用任何现代技术，否则我们不能在瓶子上这样写。哇。所以这是老式的方法。
It goes from that to a rock pit where two donkeys pull this big rock wheel and mash this now smoked agave. Then it's, then it ferments in an oak barrel for 10 days. And then it goes into a copper kettle for a distillation. And that's, that's the purity of it. It's mountain spring water and smoked agave. That's, that's all that's in it. Wow.
它从那里到一个石坑，两头驴拉着这个巨大的石轮，把这个已经烟熏过的龙舌兰捣碎。然后，它在一个橡木桶中发酵10天。然后它进入一个铜壶进行蒸馏。这就是，这就是它的纯粹之处。它是山泉水和烟熏龙舌兰。这就是，里面仅有的东西。哇。
And it's done, D'Ombres is now the fifth largest mescal in the world. Come on. That is so amazing. Yeah. I have, we have to try it. We have to try it. We have to try it. We're going to go get some.
而且它已经完成了，Dos Hombres现在是世界上第五大梅斯卡尔酒品牌。少来这一套。太惊人了。是的。我有，我们必须尝尝。我们必须尝尝。我们必须尝尝。我们要去买一些。
I will bring it to you. Yay. I will bring it to you. Even better. I love this. Yeah, that's really good. Also, just your description of it, just, I don't know. I felt like I left my body for a minute.
我会带给你们的。耶。我会带给你们的。那就更好了。我太喜欢这个了。是的，真的很棒。而且仅仅是你对它的描述，仅仅是，我不知道。我感觉我的灵魂出窍了一分钟。
It felt like I went on a little vacation. I know. A journey. And we did. We went down to Oaxaca. We found this spirit. and brought it to the marketplace. And in truth, the spirit found us
感觉像是去度了个小假。我懂。这是一段旅程。我们确实去了。我们去了瓦哈卡。我们找到了这款烈酒。并把它带到了市场上。说实话，是这款烈酒找到了我们
because it's been around for hundreds of years and we were just there to receive it. This sounds like a pretty good start on the project of living life. Yeah. It is, but like any other business, it takes a lot of effort and a lot of time and energy. Probably more than you're pouring it in there.
因为它已经存在了数百年，而我们只是恰好在那里去接受它。这听起来对“生活”这个项目是个相当不错的开端。是的。是的，但就像任何其他生意一样，它需要付出大量的努力、大量的时间和精力。可能比你投入的还要多。
And it's a lot of work. And I find that the business end of it, the case sells and this, it's not as interesting to me as the process of making it and that nurturing sense. Yeah, that and I have a production company and that's interesting too and it's good. But I'm now looking for ways to have more of that human, real life experience. I have a crazy question for you. Did you ever in your young artist's life ever do that book, The Artist's Way, by Julia Cameron? No.
而且有很多工作。我发现商业的那一端，比如案例销售这些，对我来说没有制造它的过程和那种培育的感觉那么有趣。是的，还有我有一个制作公司，那也很有趣而且很好。但我现在在寻找能获得更多那种人性的、现实生活经验的方法。我有个疯狂的问题要问你。你年轻的艺术家生涯里，有没有做过那本朱莉娅·卡梅隆的书《艺术家之道》？没有。
Excellent. I highly recommend it. I highly recommend it. Jenna did it twice. I did a few pages of it. And how did the few pages go? We're fantastic. We're different personality.
太棒了。我强烈推荐它。我强烈推荐它。珍娜做了两次。我只做了几页。那做的那几页感觉怎么样？太棒了。我们是不同的性格。
I did it twice because the first time I didn't finish and it bought it. bothered me so deeply because I realized that one of my challenges in my early artistic life was having tons of great ideas of which I finished none. Right. And so I thought I need to get over this finishing things problem. Right. Why don't I start by finishing the artist's way? Yes. And so I had done 10 of the 12 weeks and I went back and I started over again. I did all 12 weeks, and there are still things from that book, even today as an artist, that I think of. You know, one of the things is once a week, you have to go on an artist's date. Alone, by yourself, just you.
我做了两次，因为第一次我没做完，这让我非常苦恼，因为我意识到我早期艺术生涯的挑战之一就是有大量绝妙的想法，但没有一个完成的。没错。所以我想我需要克服这个“事情做不完”的问题。没错。为什么我不从完成《艺术家之道》开始呢？是的。所以我完成了12周中的10周，然后我又回去重新开始。我完成了所有的12周，而且直到今天，作为一名艺术家，我脑子里依然会想起那书里的很多东西。你知道，其中一件事就是每周，你必须进行一次“艺术家约会”。独自一人，只有你自己，仅仅是你。
That could be going to a symphony. That could be sitting in a park and watching people. That could be... I love that. Taking yourself bowling alone. Like, whatever your artist date is, you have to do this once a week. But it's all creative. It's all artistic.
那可以是去听交响乐。那可以是在公园里坐着观察人们。那可以是……我喜欢这个。一个人去保龄球馆。无论你的艺术家约会是什么，你每周都必须做一次。但这一切都是创造性的。一切都是艺术性的。
And so sometimes when I'm, like, starting a new artist, journey or whatever, I'll refer back and I'll do an artist state and I'll try to kickstart something. It's that business of living life, right? That's fantastic. It's really awesome. The bowling part threw me. That's an artist state if you want it to be. Oh yeah, take yourself bowling. To be fair, the week I got to go to an art museum. It was the week of my birthday when I got this book as a gift, but I also got a pair of roller skates. And I was a child of the 70s and I I love roller skating, and then I think I started it, and then I was like, I'm going to go roller skate. That could be an artist state.
所以有时当我，比如开始一段新的艺术之旅或别的什么时，我会回过头来参考，进行一次艺术家约会，试图重启某些东西。这就是生活这门生意，对吧？太棒了。真的很了不起。保龄球那部分把我整不会了。如果你愿意的话，那也是一次艺术家约会。噢，对，一个人去保龄球馆。平心而论，我拿到这本书的那一周去了一个艺术博物馆。那是我的生日周，我收到了这本书作为礼物，但我也收到了一双轮滑鞋。我是70年代的孩子，我我非常喜欢轮滑，然后我想我开始了，然后我就想：“我要去轮滑。”那可能是一次艺术家约会。
Well, it was an artist state that never stopped. It was an artist state that never. I still have the same pair of roller skates. They're by my front door. I still roller skate. That's got to be something, Jenna. That's great. Came out of the artist's way for me.
好吧，那是一次永不停止的艺术家约会。那是一次永不……我依然留着同一双轮滑鞋。它们就在我的前门旁。我还在轮滑。那一定得算点什么，珍娜。太棒了。从《艺术家之道》里获得的收获。
I think it came out of your birthday. My birthday buddy is Ricky Jervais. Oh, look at that. A little tie-in. I once told him that. He was like, okay. We also have Rachel Weiss Oh
我觉得那是从你的生日开始的。我的生日搭档是瑞奇·热维斯。噢，你看。有点小联系。我曾经告诉过他。他的反应是：“好吧。”我们还有瑞秋·薇兹噢
Does she share our birthday as well? Peter Sarscard This is exciting We should have a dinner We should have a March 7 Busy Phillips, that's my birthday You Busy Phillips, Ricky Phillips, are going to have dinner Oh my God, I would love that dinner
她和我们同一天生日吗？彼得·萨斯加德这太令人兴奋了我们应该吃个饭我们应该在3月7号……比西·菲利普斯，那是我的生日你，比西·菲利普斯，瑞奇·菲利普斯，我们要一起吃个饭天哪，我会喜欢那场晚宴的
We'll have dinner with Rachel That's not a bad idea For a show Oh You have a dinner with all the people who share the date You find the similarities and the differences between them, but they all have the same birthday. Brian, you have a production company. I'm so sorry we're putting you to work again.
我们要和瑞秋一起吃晚饭这不是个坏主意为了一个节目噢和所有在同一天生日的人一起吃晚饭你会发现他们之间的相似之处和不同之处，但他们都有相同的生日。布莱恩，你有一家制作公司。非常抱歉，我们又让你开始工作了。
This has to stop. Rather than that, let me give it to you and I take 10%. There it is. That's it. Perfect. And welcome to Hollywood. Oh, thank you so much for coming in today. This was fun. Thank you.
这必须停止。与其那样，不如你交给我，我抽成10%。这就对了。就是这样。完美。欢迎来到好莱坞。噢，非常感谢你今天能来。这太有趣了。谢谢。
It was so good to see you again. You too. You know, this episode, it was beautiful. It turned out great. I just rewatched it, and it's so good. Even though we all almost died, it's a great episode. And it's a classic, and people love it, and they don't know. It is a classic.
很高兴再次见到你。你也是。你知道的，这一集，真的很美。结果非常棒。我刚刚又重温了一遍，真的太棒了。尽管我们差点都死了，但它真的是个伟大的剧集。而且它是一部经典，人们都爱它，而且他们不知道。它确实是一部经典。
And now when people see us fly across the bus, I think we needed that moment. I think we need it. I think it made the pie that much sweeter. We did use it. I know. It's the actual tape. Yeah. And now you can relive it in our book.
现在当人们看到我们飞过巴士时，我想我们需要那个时刻。我想我们需要它。我认为它让后来的派变得更加甜蜜。我们确实用了它。我知道。那是实际的磁带。是的。现在你可以在我们的书里重温它了。
Thank you. Angela. That's so cool. Yeah. Oh, thank you very much. You're welcome. We love you so much. Use some dos ambres and we'll all sip some...
谢谢。安吉拉。太酷了。是的。噢，非常感谢你。不客气。我们太爱你了。来点Dos Hombres，我们一起来啜饮……
Do you have it on ice? Do you have it? Straight? Yes. How do you have it? You know, any way you like it is the right way. I like it with just neat. Maybe at one big ice cube and just let it chill without diluting it and just sip it.
你们是加冰喝吗？你们是喝……纯饮？是的。你们是怎么喝的？你知道的，任何你喜欢的方式都是对的方式。我喜欢纯饮。也许加一块大冰块，让它在不被稀释的情况下变凉，然后慢慢啜饮。
It's so great just sipping it. Do you ever mix it? Oh, yeah. All the time. It goes in a cocktail as well. So well. So well. In a margarita, in a paloma, in an old-fashioned, a nagroney.
这样慢慢品尝太棒了。你们会把它做成混合饮料吗？噢，会的。一直会的。它也可以做成鸡尾酒。非常搭。非常搭。做成玛格丽塔、帕洛马、老式鸡尾酒、尼格罗尼。
Oh, you like old-fashioned? Yeah, nagronies. Oh, yeah. Those are my faves. So good. Yeah. Try a mescal megroni. Ooh, that sounds good.
噢，你喜欢老式鸡尾酒？是的，尼格罗尼。噢，是的。那是我的最爱。太棒了。是的。试试梅斯卡尔尼格罗尼。噢，听起来不错。
You're going to love it. Well, there you have it. Our interview with Brian Cranston. I could not have enjoyed that more, Angela. He's the best. The best. Yeah. Big thank you to Brian for joining us in the studio.
你会喜欢的。好吧，这就是我们的访谈。我们对布莱恩·克兰斯顿的采访。安吉拉，我再享受不过了。他太棒了。最棒的。是的。非常感谢布莱恩来到演播室。
being so gracious with this time, and thank you all for listening. We will be back on Monday with a special Monday motivation episode with Kendra Adachi, The Lazy Genius. We can't wait for you to hear it. And then on Wednesday, it's Here Comes Trouble. So two episodes next week. Two office ladies. Two office ladies. See you then. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins.
感谢他百忙之中抽出时间，也谢谢大家的聆听。我们周一将带着一期特别的周一动力节目回归，嘉宾是《懒人天才》的肯德拉·安达奇。我们迫不及待想让你们听到。接着周三是《麻烦来了》。所以下周有两集节目。两个办公室女士。两个办公室女士。到时见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. We want to talk to you guys a little bit about new ego protein waffles. It's really good, tastes great, plus it's going to give you 20% of your daily protein. Yes, eggo protein plus waffles provide the same great taste of ego that you know and love, plus 10 grams of protein per serving.
我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾斯莉·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。我们要和大家聊聊Eggo全新推出的蛋白质华夫饼。真的很好吃，味道绝佳，而且能为你提供日常所需20%的蛋白质。是的，Eggo蛋白质华夫饼提供了你熟知并喜爱的Eggo美味，每份含有10克蛋白质。
I made the new ego protein waffles for my kids the other day. They didn't even know that they were protein waffles. They're just the eggo waffles that you know and love. I know they have protein. They're just yummy waffles. Yes. I mean, listen, I know we're talking about breakfast, but I have shared this before. I like them as an afternoon treat.
前几天我给孩子们做了Eggo的新款蛋白质华夫饼。他们甚至不知道那是蛋白质华夫饼。它们就是你熟知并喜爱的Eggo华夫饼。我知道它们含有蛋白质。它们就是美味的华夫饼。是的。我是说，听着，我知道我们在谈论早餐，但我之前分享过。我喜欢把它们当成下午的点心。
And when your teenagers come home hungry, guess what's real easy to give them? A little protein waffle. They say you can fuel your morning, but you can also fuel your afternoon. Sure can. Head to your local grocery store to fuel your morning with ego protein waffles and pancakes. available at retailers nationwide. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你的青少年放学回家肚子饿时，猜猜给他们吃什么最简单？一块小小的蛋白质华夫饼。他们说你可以为你的早晨补充能量，但你也可以为你的下午补充能量。当然可以。前往你当地的杂货店，用Eggo蛋白质华夫饼和煎饼开启活力满满的早晨。全美各大零售商均有销售。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。